c'était juste avant la pandémie désirent
y bouna ivara fêtait ses 50 ans avec sa
femme et ses cinq enfants
en 2004 il avait quitté son congo natal
déchirée par les conflits voulait
vraiment bâtir sa vie ici parce qu'il a
trouvé que ici c'est la meilleure place
d'abord seul ici il bâtit son rêve
canadien
il travaille économisent pour que sa
famille émigre est elle aussi à montréal
il le rejoint en 2010 deux enfants
s'ajoute au canada désire et bouna ivara
et salariés d'un réseau de la santé mais
rêve de devenir professeur d'université
et la cua signé c'est étiez dans un même
temps à travailler jusqu'à
jusqu'aujourd'hui il restait sa femme a
menti et préposés aux bénéficiaires
en mars la pandémie frappe elle est
alors aussi à celle des dorval avec
comme bien d'autres assez peu
d'équipement de protection comme imac et
des matériels d'aller chlt tu n'as pas
le droit même d'aller demander deuxième
lac au vide entre dans les chu celle des
et l'angoissé grandit le 31 mars à motti
avise la direction que collègues
présentent des symptômes
six voiliers mais afin de bêtises et
mortiers si jacques là quelque chose
aujourd'hui c'est quoi je vais apporter
chez moi à la maison
quelques jours plus tard les tests
révèlent qu'elle est infecte la plus
grosse problématique cela c'est que les
masses qui on prête obligatoire dès le
départ donc on sait délicats à
symptomatique là
oui a probablement des gens qui ont été
affectés à ce moment là maintenant on
voit les mares sont obligatoires les
visas sont obligatoires trop peu trop
tard pour les enfants d'un motif qu'ils
sont tous atteints de l'aco vide comme
son mari qui est durement touché
tellement qu'il est transporté au chum
où on le maintient en vie grâce à un
appareil d'oxygénation dernier cri après
plus de trois semaines
sa femme se rend lui parler même s'il
est dans le coma pour tenter de le
motiver en lui annonçant qu'elle attend
un sixième enfant tu peux pas me faire
sans rester accroche-toi pascal lalle
j'entends encore un autre vivait et ça
n'a pas marché
après 72 heures il était parti déi
rimmer le 21 mai des suites de l'aco
vide
un deuil terrible pour sa femme 1-2
teintée par la culpabilité d'avoir été
le vecteur de l'infection qui a tué son
mari
je vais simplement coupé g in
culpabilité qui mélange les pièges et
subtilement brisée elle se retrouve
veuve avec cinq enfants enceinte d'un
sixième avec pour seuls revenus son
salaire de préposés aux bénéficiaires
le syndicat espère que la famille puisse
être aidées par l'état et conseillers
juridiques sont en train de regarder si
préparons une compensation pour madame
et les descendants oui hélas de bisous
bisous dans la tragédie
quelques rayons de soleil comme les
enseignantes de l'école de quartier qui
ont offert 10 repas à la famille depuis
des semaines
l'équipe est avec moi actuellement on va
continuer de venir voir les deux petits
garçons pour qu'il réintègre doucement
d'or à jouer dehors qu'à reprendre un
peu le cours normal de la vie ici mais
la vie sans papa ne sera plus jamais la
même
surtout pour les deux plus jeunes elle
ya deux ans n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre comment papa a pu disparaître
il ya même bien même prêt à jouer cinq
minutes la demande et son père il se dit
il m'a dit
je vais voir papa j'ai moi papa je n'ai
pas capable
j'étais pas capable je les dis que papa
était au ciel c'est tout